I'm feeling well enough to start working out again and have a gym membership I would like to use.
In my rapid weight loss during my bout with staff infection last summer, I lost a little armidemout
of muscle. I have gained back plenty of weight, so calorie burden is no longer a concern.
I am 55, so gaining muscle is touted as difficult. Are there workouts that are
normals but unhealthy for a cancer patient? And where do you suggest to begin?
There was a trader that specialized in cancer workouts that you interviewed or promoted and
it's on the blog post. One point in time, are you still in touch with him and do you know if he
still offers his discounted services? First, I'll address that. No, we're not still in touch with
him, but I don't know that he is still in business that was a number of years ago. He was a local
person to be able to stay Paul too. But back to what should you do and what shouldn't you do?
So a cancer patient. So I've always said that a cancer patient should do exercises
that don't bring you to a complete anaerobic state, meaning that don't bring you to a complete
exhaustion. And why is that? Because cancer cells will reproduce in an anaerobic state.
Not get too deep into the biology, but glucose breaks down through glycolysis to make
an end product that then converts to ultimately to acetylquinsibate to go into the crem cycle.
Now cancer cells feed off of lactic acid, which is an end product that will glycolysis will
break down to especially in an anaerobic environment. So that's why when you work out really hard,
you really soar afterwards. That's lactic acid. So well, that's you're going to produce,
if you haven't worked out for a while, and even if you do some gentle workouts, you're going to produce
more lactic acid. But you don't want to push it so that you're producing a ton of lactic acid.
If you're producing a ton of lactic acid in your exercise routine,
if you don't have any history of cancer, well, that is a necessary evil in order to be able
to be able to convert lactic acid to pyruvate to acetylquinsibate in a more rapid fashion,
that is what getting in shape is. Why someone could run two miles in another person and be slightly
fatigued, and another person can't run more than two blocks without fatigued is because the one
who could run two miles is in better shape. Better shape is defined biologically as they can convert
lactic acid into acetylquinsibate more rapidly. That's what being in shape is. And that takes time
in order to do that. So when you're going to start working out, if you have a history of cancer,
you want to start really slow and gentle, so let's say you're going to try to run two
miles. And you have it run for a couple of years. And running a block is difficult right now. Start by
running a half a block and stop it. You don't want to produce excess lactic acid. So you want to go
slow. I want to get in shape so I can run two miles for crying out loud. How long is it going to take me?
Well, you've had cancer and you're older. So it's going to take you a while. It might take you
six months where you can run two miles. You got to be okay with that. You don't want to end up being in
a state of producing a ton of lactic acid because you've just produced a ton of fuel for cancer.
So don't do that. So workout, slow and gentle. Don't be intimidated. That's why I don't,
I'm not a big fan of going to gyms if you've ever met an athlete before and you've had cancer
because you'll be tempted. Because seeing other people that are in a lot better shape,
you'll be tempted to push yourself. And you don't want to push yourself too hard when you've
had a history of cancer. You want to go slow. So you don't want that peer pressure to push yourself
harder. The order you want a trader who doesn't understand what I just said because that's what a
trader does. A trader is there to push you harder to produce more lactic acid to get you in a condition
where you can convert lactic acid to acetylconz. It may really super, super fast. Therefore,
you're getting in shape faster. And now you can run five miles in six months and you can run that new,
that five mile race this summer. Well, that's not what your purpose is with cancer. You want to go
slow and slow. I would suggest weight lifting. Do we need different weights? Lighter weights. Just,
you know, just doesn't roll with being a little sore. But if you're a really super sore and you
could hardly move like, oh my gosh, I was such a good workout yesterday. I could hardly get off the
chair. You didn't weigh too much. You cannot. You do not want to be in that state. You have a history
of cancer. You're just producing cancer food. So don't do that.